[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركه
احييكم وانا راوي القاسم وهذه العربيه 360
ومن جميع ج
وانب السفير السعوديه لدى اليمن يعلن
بحثنا في صنعاء سبل الحوار بين اليمنيين
للتوصل لحل سياسي شامل
رونالدو
يعتزموا ترشح للانتخابات المقبله
ويستعينوا بجيش من المؤثرين لقياده حملته
الانتخابيه
تسريبات الوثائق السريه تربكو واشنطن
يراجع اجراءات تداول الاسرار الامريكيه
الاكثر حساسيه
نتنياهو يهاجم الحكومه السابقه لجعل
اسرائيل اكثر عرضه للهجمات ويتراجع عن
اقاله وزير دفاعه
وسيكون لدينا ايضا
[موسيقى]
رئاسه شؤون الحرمين تدشن المنصه الرقميه
لخدمه ضيوف الرحمن من خلال الذكاء
الاصطناعي
[موسيقى]
قال السفير السعودي لدى اليمن والمشرف على
البرنامج السعودي للتنميه واعمار اليمن
محمد الجابر قال ان زيارته لصنعاء رفقه
وفد عماني هدفها تثبيت الهدنه ووقف اطلاق
النار كما اكد ان العمل جارا في صنعاء
لدعم تبادل الاسرع وبحث
الحوار والعمل
على حائم
تدامن في اليمن واضاف السفير محمد الجابر
المملكه وقفت حكومه وشعبا مع اليمن منذ
عقود في احلى الازمات واكد السفير السعودي
لدى اليمن ان الجهود مستمره منذ عام 2011
لتحقيق التطلعات الشعب اليمني والعمل على
عوده الامن والاستقرار والازدهار
الاقتصادي لليمن
ينضم الينا من لندن عبر الهاتف بدر
القحطاني محرر الملف اليمني في جريده
الشرق الاوسط اهلا بك معنا استاذ بدر مره
جديده على شاشه العربيه بدون شك يعني هذه
محادثات
فاصله وتاتي بعد فتره طويله جدا من الحرب
وعلى هذا المستوى وبهذه الطريقه
وبالمكان الجغرافي لها ماذا تقول لنا هذه
المعطيات على صعيد المضمون مساء الخير
عليكم وعلى الساده المشاهدين اعتقد ان
زياره السفير السعودي الى صنعاء هي ثمره
لجهود الوساطه التي تلعبها السعوديه
بمشاركه عمانيه لما الصف اليمني وايجاد
مخرج وحل او على الاقل التمهيد لبدء
النهايه فيما يتعلق بالازمه اليمنيه اعتقد
ان الاستراتيجيه السعوديه
الخارجيه حاليا تلعب دور الوساطه في
المنطقه تتمتع بثقه الجميع او على الاقل
في الاقليم وهناك ثقه شرقيه وغربيه
بالدبلوماسيه السعوديه وبالتالي هذه احدى
ثمرات هذه السياسه الخارجيه الناجحه كنا
نتحدث دائما في المقابلات مع العربيه
والحدث وايضا كنا ننشر دائما ان السعوديه
فتحت ابوابا عديده لحل هذه الازمه وكانت
هناك اقفال الان نحن نرى ابواب سعوديه
هناك ابواب ايرانيه ايضا اتفتحت هذه نتيجه
هذه الابواب لا ننسى المبادره السعوديه
التي خرجت في عام 21 ومن ثم القنوات
الخلفيه التي فتحتها مع الحوثيين على
مستوى تمثيل اقل
بنفس المسار دعم
الاممي الى اليمن وكل مبعوثين
سيد بدر وبالتالي هل ترى بانه كل هذه
الظروف الان الظروف الاقليميه وحتى
الدوليه باتت مواتيه لسلام دائم في اليمن
واتفاق مع الحوثيين خاصه بانه الان هناك
يعني هذا التقارب الايراني السعودي الذي
بدات ثمار بالظهور
بكل تاكيد في البدايه
حتى نكون دقيقين فيما نطرح اعتقد ان
الرئيس اليمني شرح لنا في مقابله مع الشرق
الاوسط قبل عده اسابيع بان اي اتفاقات او
تفاهمات ستكون بين الحكومه اليمنيه وبين
الحوثيين والدور السعودي هنا والدور
العماني هو دور وسيط بمشاركه عمانيه طبعا
الامر
المهم في هذه كما تفضلتي بهذه المره ايران
الان ليست في موقف العدو الان ايران في
موقف محرج دوليا في موقف يغلي داخليا
فبالتالي هي تحتاج الى التهدئه لهذا السبب
راينا نجاح
الحوارات السعوديه مع ايران التي طلبت هي
في البدايه هذه الحوارات ثم راينا هناك
رعايه صينيه في في خطوه جديده اصلا على
المنطقه وتنبئ
بشكل جديد نحن لن نفرض في التفاؤل ونقول
ان المنطقه ستتحول الى منطقه اسكندنافيه
في يوم وليله او بمعايير اسكندنافيه ولكن
هذه خطوه هامه جدا لكل المنطقه لان نحن
نعرف ان السعوديه تقود مشروعا داخل
المنطقه وكثير من الدول التي تؤيد هذا
المشروع وتذهب دائما نحو التنميه السعوديه
هذه المره سوف تصدر التنميه والازدهار
والاستقرار لا يبالغ احد في التقدير ولكن
شو تصورك للبرامج
العملياتيه ولكن العقلانيه ايضا في الوقت
نفسه لاحداث هذه النقله او نقله مال لنقول
لكي لا نقول تغيير شامل نعم هناك مسوده
يتم تداولها وتدارسها بين كل الاطراف
واعتقد ان الحوثيين سيكون لديهم راي
والحكومه اليمنيه سوف يكون لديها راي
وسيكون
اللاعبون الاقليميون سواء السعوديه
بالوساطه وايضا الامارات وايضا سلطنه عمان
اعتقد الكل سوف يحفز حلفائه وكل من لديه
نفوذ عندهم بان يتوافقوا هناك مراحل هناك
الذي يهم كما تفضل استاذ طاهر هو وقت
اطلاق النار لان وقت اطلاق النار هو الذي
سيمهد لكل شيء اخر وهذا ما
تتكئ عليه الهدنه او تجديد الهدنه الجديده
هناك حديث عن تمديدها الى عام عوضا عن سته
اشهر كما اقترح المبعوث الاممي وهذه كلها
اذا لاحظنا افكار بناءه الان الجميع نتحدث
بلغه الصوت او عفوا بصوت بصوت السلام
والحوار وليس بصوت البنادق والسلاح وهذا
بحد ذاته انجاز جيد البدر يعني هناك يعني
امتدادا لنقطه التي طرحها زميلي طاهر
والتي تتحدث عنها بانه يمكن ان يبدو ان
معنا استاذ بدر استاذ بدر هل تسمعني
يبدو انه فقدنا الاتصال كنا نتحدث طاهر
بان هناك حديث عن انه الهدنه ستكون سيكون
هناك تمديد لها من سته اشهر الى سنه
تتناول ايضا المسوده الملفات الاقتصاديه
وتبادل الاسرى وايضا يعني حوار سياسي
لاحقا نقاط المطروحه بشكل مبدئي لبدايه
الحوار شكرا جزيلا
[موسيقى]
قال الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن انه يعتزم
الترشح الانتخابات الرئاسه القادمه في 20
24 وجاري التحضير للاعلان الرسمي وذلك
اثناء سؤاله من قبل مراسل قناه ام بي سي
الامريكيه وكانت وسائل الاعلام امريكيه
تحدثت في وقت سابق يا طاهر عن غموض حول
الوقت الذي سيعلن فيه بايدن بدء حملته
الانتخابيه بشكل رسمي في الوقت اظهرت
استطلاعات راي امريكيه عدم رغبه
الديمقراطيين في ترشح بايدن لولايه ثانيه
لاعاده انتخابه سيعتمد على مئات المؤثرين
على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي الذين
سيروجون لسجله وقد تكون لديهم قريبا غرفه
احاطه خاصه بهم داخل البيت الابيض وفقا ما
نشره موقع اكسوكس اكسيوس ويحذف بايدل
للوصول الى فئات جديده من الناخبين خاصه
الشباب
[موسيقى]
الطريق الى البيت الابيض ليس مفروشا
بالورود حتى امام من سكنه لاربع سنوات
باعتباره حاملا ارث ولايته الاولى الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن فهم انه يحتاج الى
اليات جديده في رحلته للصعود نحو كرسي
الرئاسه من جديد بل للبقاء عليه الاليه
يجب ان تكون مبتكره ولا مجال للتعامل
باساليب من زمن مضى
الديمقراطيون فهموا الحكايه واستوعبوا
حبكه القصه وكيف يجب ان تكون النهايه انه
زمن وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
خطه بايدن لاعاده انتخابه ستعتمد على مئات
المؤثرين على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
الذين سيروجون لسجله وقد تكون لديهم قريبا
غرفه احاطه خاصه بهم في البيت الابيض وفق
موقع اكسيوس الخطوه تهدف الى تعزيز مكانه
بايدن بين الناخبين الشباب الذين يعتبرون
حاسمين لنجاح الديمقراطيين في الانتخابات
وربما تهدف الى مواجهه العدد الهائل من
المتابعين للرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب على
مختلف المنصات مع استهداف اولئك الذين قد
لا يتابعون البيت الابيض او الحزب
الديمقراطي على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
فوفق اكسيوس يركز اربعه من موظفي بايدن
الرقميين على المؤثرين المحتوى خاصه على
منصات تيك توك وتويتر وانستجرام فتخصيص
مساحه احاطه في البيت الابيض للمؤثرين
سيكون امرا غير مسبوق وعلامه على ان غرفه
الاحاطه الصحفيه التقليديه لم تعد مركز
الرسائل الوحيد للاداره الامريكيه خطوات
تظهر بجلاء حرصه بايدن وادارته
والديمقراطيين عامه على الحصول على ولايه
جديده وعدم مغادره البيت الابيض بلال
الوجداني العربيه
ينضم الينا الدكتور ستفن فرانس ورث استاذ
العلوم السياسيه في جامعه ماري واشنطن
اهلا بك سيد ستيفن يعني استراتيجيات بايدن
الانتخابات الرئاسه عام 2024 يبدو بانها
ترمي الى استهداف فئات الشباب من خلال جيش
من المؤثرين هل سينجح برايك خاصه اذا
اعتمدنا على نتائج الانتخابات انتخابات
التجديد النصفيه من عام 2022 وايضا
استطلاعات الراي الاخيره التي تظهر تراجعا
كبيرا بشعبيته
يا
اعتقد ان هذه استراتيجيه مؤثره فالشباب
الناخبون دون سن 30 في امريكا في امريكا
هم الذين لهم الكلمه العليا الناس اينما
كانوا وكذلك حثهم على دعمهم اذا ما توجهوا
للانتخابات وهذه استراتيجيه ذكيه تعتمد
على المواقف التي يتخذها الناس في معظم
ارجاء هذه البلاد
الى اي مدى تعتقد دكتور بان حمله بايدو
بايدن حمله الانتخابات او ترشحه من عدم
اعلان ترشحه رسميا من قبل حزبه كل ذلك
يعتمد على المعركه القائمه مع شخص خاصه
بعد بدء محاكمته
اعتقد ان واحده من افضل الاشياء التي قد
يتوجه اليها الرئيس هو انه سوف يستفيد من
الصعوبات التي يواجهها الجمهوريون شعبيه
بايدن منخفضه وكذلك الامر بالنسبه لبعضنا
عندما تنظرون الى المشاكل القانونيه التي
يتورط التي يتورط بها الرئيس السابق ترامب
والمحكمه العليا والقرارات التي تنظر بمنع
الاجهاض فضلا عن بعض المسائل الاخرى حول
ومنها البيئه الثقافيه فاننا ننظر الى
سيناريو فان بان هناك جمهوريين يسعى من
خلال الحزب الجمهوري لحث مجموعه كبيره من
الناخبين الجدد ويتخذون قد قارات بعدها
اذا ما كان هناك لهم فرصه الفوز الظروف
الحاليه الان تميل لمصلحه بايدن بالنسبه
للناخبين هذا بفضل ما فعله لكن هذا لا
يعني بان هناك احترام
لما ينظره الناس الى الجمهوريون ولا
يشعرون بالسعاده اذا افعالهم وماذا دكتور
ديمقراطي التي تصف بيضا بانه شخصيه ضعيفه
وبانه لا يبعث على ثقه للداخل ولا للخارج
يعني هذه الاصوات ستتعالى ربما لاحقا
واحده من المشاكل التي لابد للمرء ان ينظر
اليها عندما نفكر بترشيح بعيد بالاضافه
الى اسئله اخرى التي طرحها الديمقراطي حول
اذا ما كان الليبراليا بما فيه الكفايه او
مثابرا بهذا الاتجاه فهذا يتعلق بقضيه
مفادها بانه رجل طاعن في السن ليتولى
الرئاسه في الولايات المتحده وانه لماذا
يجب ان اعطاء بايدن بحكم عمره ترشيحا لمده
اربع سنوات وهو في يقرا ابواب الثمانينيات
مع فضلا عن مشاكله صحيه بالاضافه الى ذلك
فان اي ديمقراطي سوف يقوم بالمشاركه في
هذه الانتخابات فاننا لا نشهد حتى اللحظه
بان اي من هؤلاء
حكام الولايات الديمقراطين قد تقدموا حتى
اللحظه ويعلمون بانهم لا يستطيعون مواجهه
حجم المنافسه عندما يخوضون المعركه مع
الرئيس بايدن لانه يمكنه بكل بساطه ان
يتفوق عليهم ذكرت بعض الامور التي قد تؤثر
سلبا على ملف بايدن اذا مركزنا قليلا على
ملف هانتر بايدن الى اي مدى التركيز
الجمهوري عليه خاصه ان تبينت المزيد من
الاسرار وثبتت بعض التحقيقات الى اي مدى
يمكن ان يكون قاضيا على ترشحه الثاني
لا نعلم الكثير عن قصه هنتر بايدن ومن
الاشياء التي لا نعلمها حتى اللحظه هي
مساله ما الذي كان تتورط به الرئيس بصوره
شخصيه في هذا الملف وهذا يوقف المطروح اذا
كان القصه سوف تكون هي جزء اساسي من
انتخاب من ان الروايه وقصص انتخابات 2020
فلا نعلم اذا ما كان هذا الحال سوف يطبقوا
في الانتخابات القادمه على الاقل ممن علمه
علنا بان هناك قصه لهنتر بايدن وقصه اخرى
منفصله
وقد لات لا
قد لا يكون هناك اي نقاط ربط بين القصتين
كما يسعى الجمهوريون دكتور ستيفن فانز
وورث استاذ العلوم سياسيه في جامعه ميري
واشنطن شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه
معنا من هناك تحياتي لك
[موسيقى]
للفوز بانتخابات 2024 جو بايدن يبحث عن
وسائل جديده للوصول الى الناخبين والحل
الامثل وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
البيت الابيض سيعتمد على مئات المؤثرين
على المنصات الاجتماعيه للترويج لسجله
وسيتم توفير غرفه احاطه خاصه بهم
الخطوه تهدف الى تعزيز مكانه بايدن بين
الناخبين خاصه الشباب والتوجه نحو الذين
قد لا يتابعون البيت الابيض او الحزب
الديمقراطي على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
خطوه البيت الابيض علامه على ان غرفه
الاحاطه الصحفيه التقليديه لم تعد مركز
الرسائل الوحيد للاداره الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
الولايات المتحده على صفيح ساخن فبعد مثول
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب امام المحكمه
في منحه اصدرت لجنه الرقابه في مجلس
النواب الامريكي اصدرت مذكرات استدعاء
لرؤساء بنوك وشركات للتحقيق بسجلات ماليه
تخص عائله الرئيس الامريكي
[موسيقى]
حرب التحقيقات والتحقيقات المضاده بين
الديمقراطيين والجمهوريين في الولايات
المتحده لا تكاد تضع اوزارها حتى تشتعل من
جديد على ايقاعات رئاسيه العام المقبل
لجنه الرقابه في مجلس وبالامريكي اصدرت
مذكرات استدعاء رؤساء بنوك وشركات للتحقيق
بسجلات ماليه تخص عائله الرئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن ونجله
اللجنه استدعت بنك اوف امريكا وكثي بنك
اضافه الى
الشريك التجاري السابق لنجل ساكن البيت
الابيض هانتر بايدن لطلب السجلات الماليه
النائب جيميرا سكين وهو العضو الديمقراطي
الاعلى في لجنه الرقابه اشتكى من ان رئيس
اللجنه جيمس كومر الجمهوري من كنتاكي كان
يحاول اخفاء المعلومات المتعلقه بالتحقيق
من الديمقراطيين لجنه الرقابه في مجلس
النواب طلبت مساعده هانتر بايدن عبر
الادلاء بشهادته امامها مستشهده بالوثائق
الماليه التي تم الاستدعاء اليها وثائق
تظهر انه حول اكثر من مليون دولار الى
افراد عائله بايدن بعد تلقيه ثلاثه ملايين
دولار من شركه طاقه صينيه في عام 2017
فالى اين يصير قطار صراع التحقيقات بين
الجمهوريين والديمقراطيين في الولايات
المتحده بلال البشتين العربيه
[موسيقى]
قال المتحدث باسم الكرملين عندما
وثائق البانتاجون التي تم نشرها على
العديد من مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي مثيره
للاهتمام للغايه ويتم دراستها وتحليلها
ومناقشتها على نطاق نا
صح لا يمكنني التعليق على هذا ولا يمكن
استبعاد هذا لقد راينا ان التسريبات مثيره
للاهتمام للغايه وتتم دراستها وتحليلها
ومناقشتها على نطاق واسع حقيقه ان
الولايات المتحده بدات منذ فتره طويله في
التجسس على رؤساء دول مختلفه خاصه في
العواصم الاوروبيه ظهرت مرارا وتكرارا
نحن نعلم ان هناك ميلا واسعا لالقاء اللوم
على روسيا في كل شيء
هذا شيء شائع وبالتالي لا يوجد شيء
للتعليق عليه
قالت وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه ان الوثائق
الاستخباراتيه التي تم تسريبها على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي شبيهه بتلك التي يتم
تقديمها لكبار القاده واضافتها الوزاره ان
بعض الصور في هذه الوثائق يبدو انه تم
تعديلها مشيرانا انه تم اطلاع الوزير
استون على التسريب يوم السادس من ابريل
الدفاع الامريكي قالت كذلك انها اتخذت
اجراءات لمعرفه كيف تم توزيع هذه الوثائق
ومن الاشخاص الذين كانت لديهم القدره على
الوصول اليها واضاف مسؤول امريكي انه يتم
التواصل مع العديد من القاده حول العالم
للتاكيد على سلامه العمل الاستخباراتي
الامريكي واشار الى ان الوثائق المسربه
مصنفه على انها عاليه السريه ومن الممكن
ان تتسبب في خساره ارواح المصادر
على اعلى المستويات اذا راويه تستمر
تحقيقات في الولايات المتحده للتحقق من
عشرات الوثائق الامنيه التي سربت من
البانتاجون وانتشرت على مواقع التواصل
والوصول الى الجهه التي سربت الوثائق
مسؤولون امريكيون وخبراء امن غربيون قالوا
انهم يشتبهون في ان شخصا من الولايات
المتحده قد يكون وراء التسريب واضاف
المسؤولون ان اتساع نطاق الموضوعات التي
تناولتها الوثائق من اوكرانيا الى الصين
واسرائيل وافريقيا تشير الى انه تم
تسريبها من احد المواطنين الامريكيين مصدر
مطلع على التحقيقات افاد بان تلك
المستندات الموسومه بالسريه والسريه
للغايه احيانا طويت على عجل واخفيت بشكل
امن لاخراجها وانتشرت تلك الوثائق على
الانترنت الشهر الماضي على منصه التواصل
الاجتماعي
بعض الوثائق في اطار التحقيقات ايضا اكد
مسؤول امني ان هيئه الاركان المشتركه في
البانتاجون تدرس قوائم توزيع الخاصه بها
لمعرفه من يحصل عاده على مثل هذه التقارير
خاصه بعد ان حملت او حملت بعض الوثائق
المسربه بعدما حملت بعض هذه الوثائق
المسربه اذا علامات من استخبارات هيئه
الاركان المشتركه كانت الوثائق كما تبعنا
سابقا اظهرت تجسس الولايات المتحده على
خصومها وحتى على حلفائها ومن ضمنهم
اوكرانيا واسرائيل تحدثنا ايضا عن كوريا
الجنوبيه بالامس وعلى الرغم من ان التجسس
جزء لا مفر منه في عالم المخابرات الدوليه
الا ان دبلوماسيين من بعض الدول المذكوره
قالوا ان الكشف عن الوثائق ربما يضر بسمعه
الولايات المتحده وينعكس سلبا عليها
[موسيقى]
تسريب الوثائق هذه ينظر اليه على انه من
اخطر الخروقات الامنيه منذ تسريبات
كما تذكرون عام 2013 بعض الجهات وصفت
تسريب الاخير بالاسوا والاكثر ضررا خاصه
وان عمر بعض الوثائق التي كشف عنها لم
يتجاوز اربعين يوما مسؤولون امريكيون
قالوا ان التحقيق في مراحله الاولى مع عدم
استبعاد احتماليه ان تكون عناصر مؤيده
لروسيا وراء التسريب اشار المسؤولون الى
ان بعض الوثائق اشارت بتفاصيل دقيقه الى
نقاط ضعف الجيش الاوكراني كما اوضحت اخرى
كيف سيتم استنفاذ انظمه الدفاع الجوي
الاوكرانيه بحلول الثاني من مايو المقبل
وفقا لمعدل استخدامها الحالي اذا
المعلومات كلها تؤثر على الوضع الميداني
الان حتى خبراء عسكريون قالوا ان مثل هذه
المعلومات ذات فائده كبيره للقوات الروسيه
خاصه بعد الكشف عن خطه عسكريه اوكرانيه ما
دفع كييف لتعديل او تغيير بعض الخطط
واعمل واشنطن ينضم الينا غانم مراسل
العربيه اهلا بك معنا بيار يعني الى اين
وصلت قضيه التسريبات ما هي اخر المعلومات
الرسميه المتوفره
هناك مشكلهتان كبيرتان تواجهان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه في هذا الوقت المشكله
الاولى وهي انهم لا يعرفون العدد الحقيقي
للوثائق التي تم تسريبها المشكله الثانيه
انهم حتى الان لا يعرفون من قام بهذا
التسريب وبالتالي هناك مشكله حقيقيه تواجه
اجهزه الامن والاستخبارات الامريكيه وهم
يعملون خلال هذا الوقت من خلال عمل بين
كافه وكالات الامن الامريكيه لمعرفه هاتين
المعلومتين ليست هناك تفاصيل كثيره
تضيفها على ذلك سوى القول هو ان الموضوع
بالنسبه لامريكيين يعتبر جدي جدا وكما
ذكرتم قبل قليل هناك مخاطر على اشخاص ان
يفقدوا حياتهم لان بعض المعلومات من
الممكن ان تشير الى من يتعامل اصلا مع
الاستخبارات الامريكيه هؤلاء الاشخاص
كانوا يعملون في الحكومه الروسيه او في
الجيش الروسي او في اماكن اخرى حول العالم
هم هددون في حياتهم بسبب هذا
التسريبتحدثت المعلومات عن انه بعض
الوثائق تم اجراء تعديلات عليها
لكي تقلل مثلا في بعضها من حجم الخسائر
الروسيه على سبيل المثال هل يعني نعرف من
خلال التصريحات الرسميه او المعلومات
المتداوله ما حجم هذا هذه التعديلات وعلى
كم من الوثائق اجريت وباي اثر ضرر محتمل
المسؤولون في البندقوم لا يريدون الدخول
في تفاصيل حول هذه التعديلات ولكن يريدون
الاشاره الى ان هذه الوثائق قد تم تعديلها
لتكون في مصلحه الجيش الروسي وضد مصلحه
الجيش الاوكراني بمعنى رفع المعنويات وخفض
المعنويات ولكن التقدير الامريكي يبقى هو
في محله الروس يصابون باضرار كبيره على
الارض في روسيا خصوصا فيما ان القوات
الاوكرانيات تتلقى الدعم المطلوب من قبل
الغربيين طيب بخصوص من يمكن ان يكون فعل
ذلك اذا ركزنا على نقطه انه قد لا يكون
عميلا ايضا يعني قد يكون اجنبيا او قد
يكون عميلا او لا يكون هل هناك احتماليه
بان يكون
جمهوريا مستقلا متضررا من سياسه الاداره
ما شابه معترضا على الحرب على اداره
واشنطن للصراع
دعنا نوضح اولا نوعيه
الوثائق ومن اين اتت هناك اشخاص عدد قليل
من الاشخاص الذين يحظون بملفات كامله اي
يحضرون بملفات عن اوروبا وعن الشرق الاوسط
عن الصين وكل ذلك فيما اشخاص اخرين مثل
لنتحدث مسؤول في الشرق الاوسط يتلقى فقط
الوثائق عن الشرق الاوسط هذه الوثائق جاءت
من ملف متكامل اذا هو ملف يشبه ملف يصل
الى وزير الدفاع نائب وزير الدفاع رئيس
هيئه الاركان المشتركه ونائب رئيس هيئه
الاركان المشتركه الرئيس الامريكي مستشار
الامن القومي هؤلاء الاشخاص هم الذين
يتلقون كل الملفات الخطوره في هذا الموضوع
هو ان الملفات هذه جاءت من شخصيه كبيره
بهذا المعنى وبالتالي يحاول الامريكيون
فهم من هو الشخص القريب من وزير الدفاع او
من رئيس هيئه الاركان المشتركه او من
الرئيس الامريكي ومستشار الامن القومي
لنقول ان هذا الشخص هو شخص امريكي ويعمل
على مستوى عال جدا في او في البيت الابيض
او في مكان عال جدا في اجهزه الاستخبارات
الامريكيه شكرا جزيلا لك اذا مراسل
العربيه من واشنطن
في العربيه 360 ايضا
طالبان تحضر المطاعم على العائلات والنساء
غرب افغانستان بداعي الاختلاط بين الجنسين
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد من جديد طاهر كانت
القياده الامريكيه المركزيه تحدثت عن هجوم
صاروخيه استهدف قاعده امريكيه في دير
الزور ولا اصابات والان مصادر العربيه
تتحدث عن قتيل وخمس اصابات جراء هذا
الاستهداف وايضا طيران التحالف استهدف
ثلاث مقرات شرق دير الزور بعد استهداف
للقاعده الامريكيه نتابع مما قاله رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي نتنياهو عن ان قدره
ردع اسرائيل تضررت وان استعادتها ستحتاج
وقتا طويلا واتهم نتنياهو الحكومه السابقه
بتعريض امن اسرائيل للخطر وجعلها اكثر
عرضه للهجمات
اسرائيل مستعده جيدا لمواجهه على كل
الجبهات قدره الردع الخاصه بنا تضررت
واستعادتها تحتاج وقتا اطول لكننا سنفعل
ذلك يجب ان اشير ايضا الى ان الحكومه
السابقه جعلت اسرائيل اكثر عرضه للهجمات
كما انها وقعت اتفاقا مع حزب الله دون
مقابل ونحن سنعمل على اصلاح الاضرار التي
ورثناها من الحكومه السابقه كما اؤكد على
ان نظام الاسد اذا سمح باطلاق صواريخ على
اسرائيل من اراضيه سيدفع ثمنا باهظا
التوتر يتصاعد في الضفه الغربيه وفي جديد
المواجهات هناك اندلعت اليوم اشتباكات بين
قوات اسرائيليه وشبان فلسطينيين جنوب
نابلس القوات الاسرائيليه اطلقت وابلا من
الغاز تجاه الشبان خلال المواجهات
المندلعه في محيط جبل صبيح التي يتظاهر
فيها الالاف من المستوطنين للضغط من اجل
تقنين منطقه استيطانيه اعلن الهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني ان مسعفيه قدموا قدموا العلاج ل
2006 عشره شخصا معظمهم اصيبوا بالغاز
المسيل للدموع اضافه لاثنتين وعشرين اصابه
بالاعييره المطاطيه واخريين بقنابل الغاز
بالراس المواجهات تاتي بالتزامن مع
التنظيم مئات الاسرائيليين مسيره للمطالبه
بالعوده الى مستوطنه اقيمت دون موافقه
الحكومه في شمال الضفه الغربيه
مسيره المستوطنين تهدف لحشد الدعم ودفع
حكومه بنيامين نتنياهو الى الاعتراف ببؤره
ايليا تار الاستيطانيه بشكل رسمي وشارك في
المسيح القومي ووزير الماليه وهما جزء من
الحكومه الحاليه التي توصف بانها الاكثر
يمينيه في تاريخ اسرائيل بالاضافه الى 20
عضوا بالكنست وخلال سيرهم نحو البؤره
الاستيطانيه التي اخليت قبل عامين في
انتظار البث في قضيتها لوح المتظاهرون من
جميع الاعمار بالاعلام الاسرائيليه وبحسب
القانون الدولي تعد جميع المستوطنات في
الدفع الغربيه والقدس الشرقيه غير الشرعيه
ويعيش فيه مستوطنات الضفه الغربيه حاليا
اكثر من
470 الف
من جانبه حمل رئيس الوزراء الفلسطيني محمد
شتيه الحكومه الاسرائيليه كامل المسؤوليه
عن كل ما يجري بالمنطقه ومحملا ايضا حكومه
نتانياهو مسؤوليه اي تصعيد
الحكومه الاسرائيليه تتحمل كامل المسؤوليه
عن كل ما يجري هنا وفي المنطقه اجمع وان
لغه العدوان والتطرف التي يدينها العالم
مطلوب من هذا العالم محاسبه هذه الحكومه
على جرائمها المتكرره يوميا والتي كان
اخرها العدوان على الاقصى ومسيره الوزراء
واعضاء الكنيست المؤيده والداعمه
للاستيطان والاجتياحات والقتل المبرمج
[موسيقى]
الا وزير الخارجيه التركيه مولود شاوش
اوغلو ان نظيره المصري سامح شكري سيزور
سيزور انقره هذا الاسبوع واضاف في تصريحات
نقلتها وكاله الاناضول ان انقره والقاهره
تقتربان من مرحله التعيين السفراء
[موسيقى]
ونذكر اذا راويه بالاخبار العاجله التي
كانت وردت قبل قليل عن مصادر العربيه قوات
مواليه لايران تخلي مقراتها بريف دير
الزور بعد استهدافات التحالف بعدما تحدثت
مصادر العربيه عن وقوع قتيل وخمس اصابات
جراء استهداف التحالف لمواقع قوات
المواليه لايران
وايضا طيران التحالف حسب مصادر العربيه
استهدافها ثلاث مقرات شرق دير الزور بعد
استهداف قاعده امريكيه قبل ذلك كانت
القياده الامريكيه المركزيه تحدثت عن هجوم
صاروخي استهداف قاعده امريكيه في دير
الزور ولا اصابات
التحالف الدوليه المتمركزه في قاعده حق
الكونيكول الغاز اسقطت الطائره مسيره حيث
سقطت في قريه الطبيه بريف دير الزور
الشرقي كما تحدثت وسائل الاعلام كرديه عن
اسقاط صواريخ كانت تستهدف حقل الكونيكوفيد
دير الزور
[موسيقى]
ثلاثه ايام من المناورات العسكريه
بالذخيره الحيه حول تايوان وصلت الى
نهايتها بعد ان اعلنت بكين اختتاما
المناورات ومع اعلان نهايه التدريبات اكدت
الصين انها ستمنع استقلال تايوان وكل
محاولات التدخل الخارجي في الجزيره التي
تعتبرها الصين جزءا منها تسعى لاستعادته
بالقوه اللازمه الامر الصين قالت ان
المناورات كانت رساله تحذير الى الجزيره
السعيه للاستقلال في تحرك لاق انتقادات
واسعه من واشنطن وقبل اختتام المناورات
كان متحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه الصينيه
اعتبر ان التدريبات في مضيق تايوان رساله
تحذير لمن اسماهم بالانفصاليين مؤكدا ان
استقلال تايوان ودعم القوى الخارجيه اكبر
تهديد للسلام في المنطقه على حد قوله
الجيش الصيني كان اجرى تدريبات بالذخيره
الحيه في مضيق تايوان تحاكي
طوق حول الجزيره بما في ذلك فرض حصار جوي
يشار الى ان المناورات التي بدات السبت
جاءت احتجاجا على لقاء جمع الاربعاء في
كاليفورنيا رئيسه تايوان ساي انجوان مع
رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي كيفن وكان اخر
انتشار كبير حول الجزيره حصل في اغسطس
الماضي مع مناورات عسكريه صينيه غير
مسبوقه ردا على زياره رئيسه مجلس النواب
الامريكي حينها نانسي بلوسي بشكل عام تنظر
الصين باستياء الى التقارب الذي حدث في
السنوات الاخيره بين السلطات التايوانيه
والولايات المتحده التي توفر للجزيره دعما
عسكريا كبيرا رغم عدم وجود علاقات رسميه
بين الطرفين
تايوان من جانبها قالت بعد انهاء الجيش
الصيني مناوراته العسكريه حول الجزيره ان
الصين تقود الامن والسلامه في المنطقه
واكد المتحدث باسم وزارات الدفاع على ان
القوات التايوانيه في حاله تاهب قصوى
للحفاظ على الامن القومي بطريقه عقلانيه
على حد قوله
ما عدم وجود نيه لتصعيد الموقف ستحافظ
قواتنا على سيادتنا وامننا القومي بطريقه
رصينه وعقلانيه ومدروسه في غضون ذلك ظلت
وحده دفاعنا الجوي في حاله تاهب قصوى انهم
يراقبون عن كتب كل هدف محتمل ويستجيبون
لحاله الطوارئ
وزاره الدفاع التايوانيه قامت ايضا بنشر
لقطات تظهر الاستعدادات العسكريه التي
تقوم بها في ظل المناورات العسكريه
الصينيه لمحاكاه الضربات على تايوان
وضع ليس بالجديد على الصين وتايوان
فالفجوه بين الجزيره والبر الرئيسي لها
جذور تاريخيه تعود الى القرون الوسطى لكن
الازمه الحديثه تولدت بعد الحرب العالميه
الثانيه
بعد الحرب الاهليه الصينيه عام
1949 استولى الشيوعيون بزعامه موتسيتونج
على الصين ليلجا القوميين في حزبكم من
تانك بقياده تشانك الى تايوان لكن الحرب
بدات عام
1954 عندما سيطرت قوات الكومنتاج على
مجموعه جزر قريبه من بر الصين كان لابد
للصين ان تخاف وتقصف الجزر لكنها فشلت في
الاستيلاء عليها وضمت عوضا عنها
جزريجيا تشان شماليه تايوان
هدوء نسبي سيطر على الطرفين حتى عام
ليتجدد القصف الصيني على الجزر التي ضمتها
تايوان ما ادى للتدخل الامريكي الذي كاد
ان يؤدي الى حرب النوويه لولا ان الصين
اعلنت وقف اطلاق النار
سنوات مضت لكن الزياره الرئيس التايواني
لتين هوي الى الولايات المتحده عام 95
كانت كافيه لاشعال الفتيل مره اخرى كونه
كان سعيا لاستقلال تايوان لتقوم الصين
باطلاق صواريخ في مياه الجزيره واستمرت
التجارب الصاروخيه لسنوات
[موسيقى]
كانت زياره رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي عام
1997 هي الاولى في التاريخ لكن النانسي
بيلوسي مشت على خطاه في اغسطس الماضي
زياره دبلوماسيه اثارت جنون الصين لتعلن
عن تدريبات عسكريه لحمايه مبدا الصين
الواحده في محيط جزيره تايوان
رد للزياره قامت به رئيسه تايوان لرئيس
مجلس النواب الامريكي كيفن في 2023
لتتزامن تدريبات عسكريه صينيه مع طول فتره
زيارتها محاكيه تطويقه تايوان او ربما
غزوها
بينما تستمر الولايات المتحده في دعمها
للجزيره الصغيره عسكريا ومعنويا اصبح
التايوان نقطه خلاف سياسيه اساسيه بين
واشنطن وبكين والتي تصر على مبدا الصين
الواحده عمر العربيه
[موسيقى]
في افغانستان فرضت حركه طالبان الحذر على
العائلات والنساء من ارتياد المطاعم
المفتوحه في ولايه هيرات غرب البلاد الحظر
جاء بعد شكاوى من اختلاط الجنسين في تلك
الاماكن هذا الاجراء هو الاحدث في سلسله
من القيود فرضتها طالبان على النساء
ابرزها منع الفتيات من الذهاب الى المدارس
بعد الصف السادس
في العربيه 360 ايضا رئاسه شؤون الحرمين
تدشن المنصه الرقميه والرابط التقني لخدمه
ضيوف الرحمن من خلال الذكاء الاصطناعي
تفاصيل اكثر مع مراسل العربيه اسامه قاسم
بعد هذا الفصل ارجو ان تكونوا معنا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد رئاسته شؤون الحرمين
المنصه الرقميه والرابط التقني لخدمه ضيوف
الرحمن من خلال الذكاء الاصطناعي وتقديم
الخدمات الرقميه داخل المسجد الحرم وايضا
خدمه اصدار تصاريح الاعتكاف والتي تلتزم
بها معايير التحول الرقمي تاتي هذه
الخدمات لتسهيل ومساعده قاصدي المسجد
الحرام في اداء مناسكهم وتطوير الخدمات
المقدمه لهم
معنا من مكه المكرمه اذا مراسل العربيه
اسامه القاسم اهلا بك اسامه حدثنا عن ابرز
هذه الخدمات التقنيه والرقميه الموجوده
بالمسجد الحرام عن تصاريح الاعتكاف كيف
تعطى وهل من يعني خروقات
اهلا وسهلا طاهره للراويه تحيه طيبه لكما
ولجميع مشاهدينا العربيه انقل لكم الصوت
والصور اليوم من باب تسعه وتسعين باب
الملك فهد احد اكبر الابواب التي تؤدي الى
صحن المطاف والتي تشهد ايضا هذه الايام
ازدحاما جديدا على مستوى الزوار وقاصدين
مسجد الحرام وايضا الداخلين الى صحن
المطاف نعم اتحدث اليوم عن الخدمات
التقنيه الروبوتات التقنيه الموجوده اليوم
في المسجد الحرام تشهد رئاسه شؤون الحرمين
منذ بدايه شهر رمضان المبارك اكثر من خدمه
تقنيه كخدمه مكاني خدمه مكاني هي ملصق
يوضع على احدى الاعمده المتواجده في ساحات
المسجد الحرام يعرف بها الزائر او قاصد
بيت الله الحرام المكان الذي يتواجد فيه
او مكان الشخص الذي يود اللقاء به ايضا
الروبوتات التقنيه التي تترجم هنا في
المسجد الحرام تتم ترجمه اكثر من واحد
وخمسين لغه ثم ايضا الروبوتات تقدم مياه
زمزم في داخل صحن المطاف هذه الخدمه احدى
اكبر الخدمات المتواجده اليوم في المسجد
الحرام التي نشهدها الان عبر الكاميرا
العربيه هي اصدار اسواره الكترونيه
للاطفال بحيث يتم اعطاء الطفل حسب اسمه
وايضا رقم جوال والده او احد دويه ليتم
العثور عليه في حال فقده في المسجد الحرام
نتحدث الان اذا عن هذه الخدمه المتواجده
هي طباعه تذكره من طريق الخدمه الذاتيه
لنظام سحابي يعطي التذاكر الذكيه لاي طفل
متواجد في ساحات المسجد الحرام نتحدث
اليوم عن هذه الخدمه الكبيره التي اعطت
مساحه كبيره لكي لا يفقد الاباء ابنائهم
حيث كانت هذه الخدمه تعطي الكثير جدا لذوي
هؤلاء الاطفال نشهد الان صدور احدى
الاساور الالكترونيه وتعطى الان للطفل في
حال فقدانه يتم التواصل مباشره مع احد
ذويه طبعا راويه وطاهر ونحن نتحدث اليوم
عن هذه الخدمات المتواجده في المسجد
الحرام نشهد ايضا اليوم توافد الكثير من
الزوار والمعتمرين وصلت اعداد الزوار
معتمرين الى هذه اللحظه الى حوالي 18
مليون زائر ومعتمر اما بالنسبه للاعتكاف
نعم رئاسه شؤون الحرمين كان لها رابط
لاصدار تصاريح الاعتكاف هناك اكثر من
ثلاثه الاف معتد ومعتكسفه سواء هنا في
توسعه الملك فهد او التوسعه السعوديه
الثالثه
لازم تفوتي عليها لانه بضل يحكي للصبح
اسامه ما شاء الله عليك يعطيك الف عافيه
اسامه حدثنا عن التجهيزات للعشر الاواخر
نعم راويه نعم طاهر التجهيزات العشر
الاواخر وما بحكي كثير تجهيزات اليوم نعم
نتحدث عن
العمال المتواجدين اليوم في ساحات المسجد
الحرام هناك اكثر من اربعه الاف عامل
وعامله في تنظيف وفرش جديد المسجد الحرام
هناك ايضا اكثر من الف عامل لتقديم سقيا
زمزم وصلت عدد الاشارات اليوم الى حوالي
25 مليون لتر مقدم للزوار والمعتمرين تحدث
اليوم ايضا عن اداره التفويج والحشود هناك
خطه تنظيميه محكمه من قبل رئاسه شؤون
الحرمين وايضا الجهات الامنيه والوكالات
المسانده للحد من الازدحام ومنع الزوار
المعتمرين من الدخول الى مواطن ازدحام تم
تخصيص ست بوابات للدخول الى صحن المطاف
وست بوابات للصلاه ثم ايضا استكمال تهيئه
اعمال التوسعه السعوديه الثالثه بالخمسه
ادوار وايضا السطح والتي تستقبل ويتسع
لحوالي مليون و 200 الف مصلي في هذا الوقت
كل هذه الخدمات بالتاكيد تاتي لان يشعر
هذا الزائر او قصف بيت الله الحرام
بالطمانينه وان يستمر باداء مناسكه بكل
يسر وسهوله
شكرا جزيلا لك اسامه القاسم اختصر شكرا يا
اسامه يعطيك الف عافيه يعطيك الف عافيه
وينعاد عليك ان شاء الله تحياتي اليك
[موسيقى]
شكرا لا تزال اثار الزلزال المدمر في
تركيا ترخي بظلالها الاليمه على ذوي
الضحايا يا طاهر الذين يختبرون الم الفقد
والفراق في اول شهر رمضان يقضونه دون
احبتهم الذين فقدوهم تحت الانقاض ام احمد
اللاجئه السوريه تختبر هذه
[موسيقى]
ومين هن اولادك اللي ماتوا بنتين وصبي
بنتين بنت عمرها 17 سنه وبنت عمرها اربع
سنين والصبي عمره 12 سنه كان هذا جزءا من
مقابله ام احمد مع قناه العربيه في مخيم
من مخيمات مدينه الاصلاحيه بولايه غاز
عنتاب بعد ايام من الزلزال المدمر الذي
ضرب جنوبي تركيا
اللاجئه السوريه فقدت اطفالها الثلاثه
نتيجه الزلزال وتعرض زوجها لحادث اليم في
سوريا بعد انتهاء مراسم دفن اطفاله هناك
ولا يعلم احد عنه اي شيء حتى اللحظه الى
اسطنبول جاءت ام احمد للحصول على بطاقه
حمايه مؤقته لها ولطفلها الناجي من تحت
الانقاض لكن طيف اطفالها الثلاثه لا
يفارقها في اول شهر رمضان تمضيه بدونهم
رمضان الماضي كتير كان حلو
اي والله كان ولادي معي أطلع جيبلهم يعني
حلوة عيد اشتري لون ثياب كتير كنا مبسوطين
الحمد لله بس هذا هذا رمضان كتير ماساوي
علي
اللي صار معي ما بصدق هلا بحسه كانه حلم
لم تنجح في الحصول على بطاقه حمايه مؤقته
لذلك قررت العوده مجددا الى ولايه غاز
عنتاب لكن الى اين ستعود فمنزلها تهدم ولا
مكان يؤويها ما مشي حاله هوياتي هون وبدي
ارجع هلا على الاصلاحيه
غازي عنتاب بس ما عم بعرف وين بدي ابرك
يعني بيتي انا انهدم نعم
بعرف الحياه اغلقت ابوابها في وجه ام احمد
العالقه في ذكريات الماضي والرافضه
للانتقال الى قادم ايام لا يجمعها مع
اطفالها الذين رحلوا وزوجها الذي لا تعلم
عنه شيء زيدان زنجلو العربيه اسطنبول
ومباشره الى هذه الصور التي تصلنا من
اسرائيل
للتظاهرات الحاشده التي يلوح بها
المتظاهرون بالاعلام الاسرائيليه هذه
التظاهرات هي ضد رئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتنياهو وتخص القرارات الحكوميه الاخيره
بخصوص التعديلات القضائيه بشان اصلاحات
القدم اذا تجدد هذه التظاهرات في تل ابيب
تعديدا
للدفاع وبانه اسرائيل مستعده لمواجهات كل
الجبهات الى اخبار الساعه والزميله ميسون
واهد مساء النور ماذا لديك مساء الخير
طاهر سنبدا طبعا اعلان الرئيس بايدن نيته
للترشح لانتخابات 20 24 ايضا عن زياره
سفير السعوديه الى صنعاء بهدف تثبيت
الهدنه وايضا الوصول الى حال سياسي
بالاضافه ايضا الى الوثائق الامريكيه
المسربه التي ما زالت تتصدر المشهد تفضل
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات